no word strikes more fear into the heart
of fox news anchors known for syllable
shakes the 1% more to its core than
socialism the problem with socialism is
I would President Obama want America to
be more socialist than capitalism 43
percent of 18 to 29 year olds think
socialism is okay socialism is a dirty
word in American politics
it's lobbed at presidents to try and
tear them down and use my outsiders to
set them apart but what is it socialism
is a political and economic theory of
social organization that advocates the
means of production distribution and
exchange should be owned or regulated by
the community as a whole
there are many different types of
socialists but the main idea is that the
rich and the powerful don't get to call
all the shots when it comes to the
economy but here's the thing that no one
will tell you America is already
socialist here's why Americans work like
socialists you know those two days a
week where your boss camper at you what
do they call the weekend the weekend was
never part of big businesses planned it
was fought for and won by the labor
movement of the late 19th and early 20th
centuries a labor movement that was full
of socialists in 1938 Congress passed
the Fair Labor Standards Act it
established a 40-hour workweek minimum
wage and eliminated child labor which is
a good thing unless you run a sweatshop
some of the most remarkable Americans
maybe even some of your heroes were
socialists Mark Twain Ernest Hemingway
Jack London Caesar Chavez
Helen Keller even Harry Houdini was a
socialist now America has Bernie Sanders
who calls himself a Democratic Socialist
and
lover whose showdown but I'm still
waiting on Lethal Weapon 5 the picket
line whenever you get on a highway drive
over a bridge use electricity from a dam
or go to a school or hospital you're
probably partaking in American socialism
to pull the country out of the Great
Depression
over 30,000 Public Works programs were
sponsored by the government under
Franklin D Roosevelt New Deal
infrastructure infrastructure that's now
crumbling even with President Obama's
2009 economic stimulus package which
tried to pull us out of the most recent
Wall Street induced financial meltdown
but the New Deal wasn't labeled
socialism except by its critics
FDR defended it saying the test of our
progress is not whether we add more to
the abundance of those who have much it
is whether we provide enough for those
who have little the New Deal also
included unemployment insurance and
Social Security making sure that you can
get back on your feet when you lose your
job and you're taking care of when you
get old and crotchety you could call it
big government socialism or just looking
out for one another the military the one
area of spending no one would dare call
socialist and yet it's largely funded by
you the taxpayer strange for all the
wars the US has fought trying to stop
the spread of socialist ideas you think
that war was a capitalist venture around
27 percent of your tax dollar goes to
fund the biggest and most expensive
military in the world with a budget of
five hundred and ninety eight point five
billion dollars compare that to spending
on unemployment social security
education science and infrastructure and
it looks like the military is red all
over good god y'all welfare is also one
of those things that's bad mouth for
being socialist because why take care of
the needy but what about corporate
welfare since 2000 Uncle Sam is given
sixty eight billion dollars in business
grants and tax credits two-thirds of
which has gone to large corporations
transportation and energy are the
biggest beneficiaries even some of the
biggest corporations like Walmart
encourage their employees to use food
stamps and other government services
because a pair
the most profitable corporation in the
world can't pay a livable wage it's
almost like socialism is fine if it
helps the rich but terrible if it helps
everyone else in the end of the day
socialism is as American as apple pie
bought at a Walmart with food stamps
you